[Música]
beckham quer ganhar
é isso
esse é o maior canal do youtube o brasil
fazer o que existe é isso aí galera que
aceite meu canal tudo com vocês
nos treinos eu sempre usei filme muito
treloso quando era criança sempre por
aquele menino que foi aquele enganado
alegará que minha mãe não pode sentir
muito silêncio que se tiver muito
silêncio porque o me está fazendo alguma
desgraça era eu o conhecemos
eu vou pintar os cabelos de acasos um
guia é mulher também gosta dessas coisas
mas cossío linhas 1 e 2 do mundo também
eu também gostam é maçã do amor reboots
silêncio
eu não falei eu era o cara que fazia
confusão na brincadeira porque eu nunca
está satisfeito está a acontecer de
brincadeira eu não sei se você mora mas
onde eu moro tinha chamada vaca amarela
tinha música e se a vaca amarela acabou
na panela que falar primeiro com uma
bosta dela todo mundo cala a boca ao som
de vaca amarela o livro de ter caído mas
dentro do show quebra a cara toda porque
tá chorando o ska a boca cala a boca
eu fiquei visita em casa o rapaz faz
silêncio volta vai começar a chamar ela
acabou na panela que foi o primeiro
namorado dela
ele escutava nenhum pio eu ser criado
confusão que toda brincadeira com seu
lamborghini e económica de vaca amarela
bom ó então bora bora na câmara ela
passou pela janela quem fala primeiro
como gostar dela falou vai comer gosta
vai acabar ela e criança leva as coisas
a sério nome de vadão que semana passada
eu já fui a mulher do pai já é mau a
assembléia do paraná comemora de vaca é
pai de mais de brincar também no colo só
que eu não sei por uma pequenininha mas
branquinho e mails cabelo tapas e café
com leite e café com leite é pai de mais
caro a quem não conhece o café com leite
é a cota para a criança na brincadeira
geralmente todo mundo que tá brincando
gola que aquela brincadeira de correios
cada pessoa se trancou a pessoa é quem
está aplicando essa brincadeira já metem
14 anos cabo 38 quer brincar também é
enquanto nós como café com leite ou seja
a gente não tem importância
ninguém conta da gente acredita na
importância a gente é só uma peça cara
engrenagem que é só uma marioneta mão do
sistema que está todo mundo brigando
todo mundo correndo todo mundo feliz eu
estou como devagar porque eu sou o quê
café com leite a moça não tem noção do
que é uma merda é um cara seu café com
leite não quando você o café com leite a
brincadeira fica mais ou menos assim é e
você fica assim
[Música]
e pick escolhe abrigou picolé de escolha
era pop aonde você não vai falar top
porque top é uma gíria a palavra eu falo
top e aí eu falo só porque uns o top 70
km tirar o direito de falar top 100 que
fala a top é top a partir de hoje os
meus fãs se chama tops nós somos top
shelf top e brincar de esconde era top
picks conde com as pessoas de são paulo
e rio de janeiro mas o pessoal do
nordeste chama se esconda e não se
esconda de se esconder não se esconda de
se esconda mesmo não é brincadeira é
bancado se esconda o despique esconde
outro lado o brasil de esconde-esconde
pagado nordeste e se escondeu e ricardo
se esconda na verdade que brincava com
meus amigos york café com leite o café
com leite né não onde eu crescer e
lógico que as pessoas crescem isso que
acontece eu tô até barba eu brinquei
muito doces conta abrigados escolher
radical demais cara tu é doido mesmo
robô quando pegavam todos um menino
amigo do carro que morava pega-se se
combinava meu irmão foi o seguinte 8
hora todo mundo na rua praticado e
quando a vitória essa rua tava cheia de
menino que fez o menino vem confirmar
que o meu deus do céu se pegassem muito
de repente se eu fizesse um sabonete não
davam palmolive agora embora que dava
menina era muita e ouvir em a menina na
base de uma 70 100 crianças e você pode
falar a verdade a gente tinha que contar
até 100 mas ninguém contava até sem
direito a gente cantava assim a 27 28 29
30 84 87 79 por época tudo com dois gols
de petkovic na rua logo ele se escondeu
já vou meu amigo a chave mais citado
harry potter
e aqui nós isso é dor ea alegria de mais
belas e menino escondido oaxaca 98
achava o menino 99 o dinheiro entrar no
carro não vendo como ela tava escutar a
musiquinha e uma pessoa estragar a
alegria de deus aqui te dá um vazio tão
grande calor do esforço e força de
vontade foi por água abaixo por uma
merda de 1 31 salve todos sábado jogo
sem vergonha galera brincava é verdade
ou consequência brincar de mais verdade
consequência não satisfeito com verdade
ou consequência a criança criou a pêra
uva maçã salada mista que era quando a
gente era mais novo e essa é a do
brincar de ninguém queria ser café com
leite nerd bock a pêra uva maçã salada
mista era a primeira chance você tinha
de beijar a menina que você gostar
negada chamava e da bica de pedra uma
salada mista você só dava observando
aqui parabéns à minha irmã se ela foi
meu e eu vou eu vou brincar eu até agora
o meu patrão zico aqui era só você que
brincava com essa minha era você mais
uns oito cabral dar duas o você beijava
que você gostar você ver a menina que
você gostava de beijar outro cara na tua
frente sem poder fazer nada na nossa
sorte eu queria ser café com leite nem
tá e eu lembro que o brinquedo para uma
salada mista menina beijou 12 cara 12 eu
me senti a tia da cerveja no carnaval a
ligar para tia da cerveja fica só vender
cerveja observando as pessoas vejam por
um pássaro e beijando beijando beijando
beijando beijando só faltava o abate a
brincadeira caixa d'água sobre o cachê
da caixa d'água seguinte a opção foi o
bebedouro da escola bebe água não está
acomodado cruzados e pode chegar e dizer
'sim acionado ea pessoa é obrigada a
beber quantos copos d'água você mandar
eu ia beber cachaça tema vacilar vacila
tj negou ter cruzado após cooptado 12
fazer o que cabe a ficha limpa menino
criança é um cão estão parados tá todo
mundo quieto aqui ó que é tarde ninguém
foi nada fácil e me obrigou a jogar
bolinha de papel naquele seja lê
leiam o livro eça de demônio tá quieto
cara vai procurar coisa para como é que
pode levar jogou e roxo limpa
ai neto pegou jovovich erro é o que
chulepa preto vai-vai jogou erro a não
posso eu eu sou café com leite café com
leite venha cá o nicho lei agora a
brincadeira que eu mais odiava quando
era criança se chamava metadinha eu não
sei como se chama na região de você mas
não me chamava metade é o seguinte você
está comendo alguma coisa não tá com
dedos cruzados e pode chegar e falar
metadinha que a pessoa é obrigada a lhe
dá a metade daquilo que ela tava comendo
e você vai dar se não a gente faz uma
revolução melhor filme escolhido sabe
boa e não faz comigo não é assim você
não tá com de cruzar mãe foi comigo não
acaba é palma nem o avaí pega o meu
biscoito e também não nunca maior preto
ver em itaipu
muito obrigado a assistir esse vídeo é
que se você gostou de se ver o clipe
gostei aqui no youtube eu quero que você
comente aqui no youtube se você for um
leque treloso comenta a moradora diz que
você fez quando era criança bota lá no
facebook não possui esse vídeo
brincadeira de infância clique em curtir
lá e marca seus amigos que também
fizeram suas brincadeiras de infância
segue nas redes sociais que vai na
descrição do vídeo tão junto é na itália
e ban